what nothing it's just um you know we're
makeup do you every evening I destroy my
face and every morning I rebuild it I
knew really I always thought you were a
natural beauty doesn't matter what
Mother Nature gives you all women are
taught at a young age to hate the way
they look
how'd you know wear makeup to you why
don't you ask the 200,000 makeup addicts
who watched my makeup tutorials only men
can get away with looking like
every day
you think I look like you have
flaws what are they
Matt you have to understand if we tell
you there's no going back
if Diaz wear eyeliner and the
conversation ends here you wake up in
your bed and believe you're beautiful
pick the scarlet lip liner and we'll
show you how deep the rabbit-hole of
insecurity goes
[Music]
your skin is both oily and flaky I don't
understand how that's possible
you remind me of the Green Giant over
berries are like a brighter
[Music]